Today, we're going
to be building
a Harry Potter style magic wand
with a shocking twist.
[Music]
Guys, I love Harry Potter.
I love Harry Potter so much.
I've read all the books.
I've watched all the movies,
and just a fan all around.
And something that I've
been wanting to build
for a long time is a magic wand
that actually will deliver
a small electric shock.
Now, I don't want anything
that's going to truly
incapacitate or injure someone,
but I did want something
that's sort of a prank,
and you can just touch someone
with it, press a button,
and they get zapped
a little bit.
So, here's what
we're going to be doing.
We've got these
gag shocking pens.
If you've never seen one
of these before, here's
how they work.
It's pretty simple.
There is a functioning
pen to it,
but it looks
like it's gonna be a click pin.
And so you give it to someone
with the pen not extended,
they try and click it,
and when they do,
it's zaps them.
The body of the pen
and the top here are conductive,
and when you press
down on the top,
it connects all
of the wires inside,
and it delivers a small buzz.
It's not something
that's going to hurt,
because it's intended as a joke.
It's just startling
when it's suddenly
buzzes your thumb,
instead of just extending
the pen at the bottom.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to take all
of the electronic guts
out of this pen,
change things up a little bit
so we have a button
that turns it on and off,
and some leads
at the front of the wand.
Hopefully, we'll end up
with a wand with a shock.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll use a couple of dowels
and the inside parts
of a shocking gag pen
to build a wand
that can deliver a tiny
electric shock to your friends.
Along with the dowels
and the shocking pens,
that were going to take all
of the insides out,
we've got a few things
we're going to add in.
First, I picked up a set
of these other batteries.
I grab these at Harbor Freight.
This whole pack was about $4.
There's a lot
of different varieties.
We're going to be using one
of these smaller sizes.
The bigger ones won't be able
to fit too well.
I also grab this cheap
little flashlight.
It didn't even work
when I bought it.
That's okay,
because all we want
is the push button
on the inside of the flashlight.
We're going to be
taking that out.
If you have a good way to buy
those buttons individually,
that works too.
This just happened
to be at the store
where I already was.
And then I also have a couple
of varieties of wire.
This is some insulated wire
that I pulled out of
some old Cat 5 cable,
and this right here is
a decorative copper wire.
It has an enamel coating on it,
and that enamel coating
is actually non-conductive.
You can scrape it away to get
to a conductive portion
of the wire,
so this stuff works really
well as enamel wire,
which is also
weirdly hard to find.
Now, the reason we
got additional batteries,
even though the shocking pens
do come with some,
is that the batteries
in the pens are really weak.
These pens are
not very expensive,
and the batteries that come
with them are pretty cheap.
They die quickly,
and I suspect that they
don't have quite the voltage
that they're supposed
to in the first place.
These batteries that I'm using
are actually also fairly cheap,
but they definitely seem
to have more of a charge
to them than the ones
that come in the pen.
Time to break
into our shocking pen,
and look at
the electronics inside.
So this part just
sort of twists off,
that's some metallic insides
that just kind of get shredded
as we do that.
This plastic portion up here
we're going to use part of
this down here,
we're not going
to be using in there.
Glued together, so the easiest
way to separate them...
Just to break through it.
That's okay because we
didn't want this portion.
We're just going
to be using this top bit.
So now this splits apart,
we can see our insides.
Here's what we need.
There's this portion,
here which has all
of our connection points
to the wires.
I'm actually going
to be taking my gloves off.
The point of this thing is
that it gives off
an electric shock,
and I want to be able
to feel it to know
that I have it set up right.
If it's not working correctly,
I need to know.
And easiest way to do that is
just to touch the things,
and see if it's zapping me.
So let's take a look
at this thing,
how it works.
So if I am touching this spring,
which is in contact
with those batteries,
and I touch this end as well,
it starts buzzing,
and you've, maybe heard
my voice jump a couple of times
when I touched it by accident
when I wasn't expecting it.
It's not that
it's super painful.
It's just surprising
when you're not ready for it.
So as long as I'm in contact
with this lead here
and this lead here,
it gives me a nice little buzz.
We don't want it
to be always on.
We want to add a switch,
a button on the outside,
and that's why we have
our tiny little flashlight here.
[Music]
This is why we
got the flashlight.
It is for this
tiny little switch.
It doesn't click on it off
the same way as some switches.
It's just if you're holding
down the button, it's on,
and that's exactly what we want.
We only want the electricity
of the one to be connected
while we're pressing the button.
We are not going
to be using the LED bulb,
so we can just clip that off.
There's our little button.
We'll have this red wire
here going to our button.
We will take the spring off
and attach it up here.
We'll have the wire
on the other side
of our button going back,
touching the spring,
and then a second wire,
coming off of that,
going out through our wand.
Those two will run all the way
up to the tip of the wand,
and that's what we're going
to use our shocking point.
We've got a couple of
these pieces of the plastic case
that were inside of the pen,
and we actually
do want to use those.
We just need to trim
them down a little bit,
sort of the right size.
Now, these two,
the little pegs at the bottom,
hold this all together...
It's very nice and compact.
That's something we can fit
inside the handle of the wand.
One of the trickiest things
about this whole setup is
how small we need
to get everything.
We really need to compact
it down quite a bit.
So I'm just going to do
a little bit of wire bending
on these pieces right here
to make everything fit
a little bit nicer.
So before this little plastic
plate was facing straight up,
I have bent it back in
and over again.
So you can see
that the wire is here
are doubled around.
That's just going to keep
everything a little bit shorter,
and that will make it
so we can fit inside
the handle of our wand.
Our springs and our
battery are in place.
So now, we're just going
to take this cover,
and throw it back on.
That will stop our batteries
from popping out
like they like to do.
All right.
This part is prepped.
Let's set that aside
for a few minutes.
Get started on the want itself.
Right here, I have
a 1/2 inch dowel.
We need to run wires
through a portion of this.
We're going to cut it off,
so it's about that long.
We're going to cut it
in half lengthwise first though.
We want to be able to run wires
in the inside of this dowel,
and carve out a channel,
and then glue it together
around the wires.
[Music]
Now, we need to split
it in the long way.
And to do that,
we're going to use a band saw.
[Music]
Now, we want to choose a length.
I think that looks pretty good.
I'm going to cut
that off right about here.
Because we use the bandsaw,
these two pieces fit
really nicely together.
However, it does leave a little
bit of tooth mark on the inside,
so we're just going
to take some sandpaper,
and try and smooth
that out a bit.
[Music]
And we want to cut a channel
all the way down the length
of the whole thing,
and we can cut into one side
or both sides,
either way works.
This split actually ended
up being quite even,
and so I think we're just going
to cut a little bit of a groove
into both of those.
There's lots of ways you
could cut this groove.
You could use just a razor blade
and a steady hand.
I'm going to try
using a rotary tool.
I think it will be
a little bit quicker and easier.
[Music]
What we need is a channel
that's just big enough
for some of this wire.
Two strands of it,
and they come with
two strands twisted together.
So that's just like...
To be able to fit down
through the channel of the wand,
and now, a space
that we can glue them together,
and have the size
of the wood meeting up.
One other change
we're going to do.
You can see
that I didn't take the channel
all the way to the end of wood.
And that's because we don't just
want a big open channel there.
We're going to add
two more smaller channels
coming off of that,
and a little bit of the wire
with the coating stripped off is
what's going to stick out
from the top of those.
[Music]
Got our two lead wires.
However, these are just
a little bit to stabby.
We don't want to
be injuring people.
We're going to be shocking them,
but it's a light shock that's
not supposed to really hurt.
So what we're going to do to
round these out is we're going
to add a little drop of solder
on to the tip of each one.
[Music]
Now, we need to glue this wire
inside that channel.
[Music]
That should be plenty of clamps.
While that glue is drying,
let's work on some of the
internal portions of our wand.
We've got the basic housing
and battery set up,
and that's all going to fit
inside of our handles.
So now we need to go
about making that handle.
We're actually going
to drill a hole lengthwise
down into the dowel,
and that's gonna be
just large enough to fit
our electronics inside,
as well as working
as a connection point
between the handle
and the shaft of the wand.
With the hole drilled out
into the larger dowel piece,
we can see that everything
can now fit down inside.
That's exactly what
we're going to need.
We do want to do a little bit of
decorative work on the handle,
and we're actually going to do
that right now.
Because it's going to end up
thinning out parts of the top,
and we just want to make sure
that we have
everything all complete,
and lined up just right.
It's gonna be
a little bit easier
if we do this part
first rather than after.
[Music]
All right, there's some
decoration put on the handle.
I've seen some other people do
some interesting stuff,
making their own Harry
Potter wand handles,
where they use things
like hot glue
or melted wax to add
some other texture onto those.
If that's something
you like doing,
by all means,
you should go ahead and do that.
For this one,
I'm just going
to use some sanding,
give it a little bit of shape
and texture down at the bottom.
You can see I didn't do
too much of the top.
That's because the walls
up at the top
where I've drilled it
out are fairly thin.
I didn't want to risk
cracking or sanding
through the edges there.
So the top part
is mostly untouched,
and I did quite a bit
more texture down at the bottom.
Wingardium Leviosa.
Which is not going to work
because the ones not done yet.
Time to do a little
bit more soldering.
[Music]
Our button is going to go
on the outside of the wand.
So we need to add
some access points
for the wires to go
through the side of the handle.
We're now using
our smallest drill bit.
[Music]
Glue has had plenty
of time to dry.
Now, we need to shape
this little bit more.
Right now, it's just
shaped like a dowel.
That's not very exciting.
So back to the belt sander.
I'm going to take some
of these sides down,
make it a little more tapered.
There we go.
As I was tapering it,
I decided I kinda wanted to
match the handle a little bit,
and it gave it a little bit
of a spiral cut to it.
Kind of makes it look like
a unicorn horn or something.
Okay.
So now we need to have
one of these two wires
attaches to the spring,
and the other one
of those wires attaches
to this green piece
of wire here.
So let's clip
everything shorter,
do some more soldering.
[Music]
All right. I gotta try something.
It's not going to feel good.
[Music]
That like causes
a muscle in here
to just completely cease all at once.
Okay.
Last thing I want
to do is just add a bit
of finishing color to this.
So it doesn't just look
like plain pine,
so we're at least going to make
it look a little bit snazzier.
[Music]
The wand is complete,
and I have some volunteers.
I volunteered them
to participate in me
testing this out.
Josh, how do you
feel about that?
I feel great.
Yeah.
I feel like a victim.
Don't worry.
You can shock me with it too.
So, it's pretty simple.
There's a button,
and then these two leads have
to make contact with the skin.
It's a little bit of a tingle.
And and it depends.
It changes a lot depending on
where on your skin it is.
Yeah.
So I've had lots of times
where just like
buzzes a little bit,
and then I've had times
where I feel it running all
the way up through my fingers.
If I put it right
here on my arm,
I can actually feel it buzzing.
It's nothing crazy
like a taser or stun gun.
Exactly.
I didn't want something that
was going to like injure people.
It's completely involuntary,
isn't it?
Makes the muscles contracted.
Let's go for
a right, right here.
[inaudible] on me.
I'm going to try one finger on,
and then touch the other side
with my tongue.
[Music]
I can feel it in my finger
and my tongue.
I don't feel it traveling
the path between them.
All right.
But I have done it on my tongue.
Just one side on your tongue,
and the other side
on Josh's tongue.
What?
No.
We're not going to try that.
Just kidding.
That's funny.
The trick of this
is really engineering
everything to be small enough
to fit inside the handle,
but it works,
and you can wave it around,
and do magic spells.
Wingardium Leviosa.
It's Leviosa.
Made the camera float away.
I'm very talented wizard.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
is going to take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to our channel.
So you never miss out on video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.